we have had weeks and weeks of Donald
Trump saying James Comey told me I
wasn't personally under investigation he
said it once he said it twice he said it
three times according to Donald Trump
and James Comey did confirm at his
testimony last week that at a particular
point in time months ago that was true
Trump was not under investigation and
now you must know where I'm going with
this
coinciding with Donald Trump's 71st
birthday we've learned that Donald Trump
is under personal investigation for
obstruction by special prosecutor Robert
Muller and this is sort of getting lost
in the neverending constant sequence of
news this is arguably the biggest news
on the Russia scandal in quite some time
and of course Donald Trump is calling it
fake officials are saying that special
prosecutor Robert Muller's investigation
into Russia and Trump collusion now
includes looking at Donald Trump
personally for possible obstruction of
justice the President of the United
States is personally being investigated
and this investigation is in some way
shape or form about a year old at this
point and rather than shrinking pad it
is growing it is growing with every bit
of news that we get and now it
personally includes the President of the
United States this does not change or
contradict that James Comey told front
months ago that he was not under
investigation at the time that was
presumably true James Comey is no longer
in charge months have passed and now
Donald Trump is under investigation and
five people briefed on the interview
requests that have been out there so far
related to this speaking on the
condition of anonymity because they
weren't authorized to actually discuss
this are saying that Daniel Coates
current Director of National
Intelligence Admiral Mike Rogers head of
the NSA and Rogers is recently departed
deputy Richard alleged have agreed to be
interviewed by robert muller as
early as this week and really this idea
that Trump wasn't personally being
investigated was bogus to begin with
because of course his campaign was being
investigated and who's at the head of
the campaign the candidate Donald Trump
yeah so while while technically speaking
it appears to have been true that at a
certain point Trump wasn't being looked
at as an individual he was of course
part of the broader investigation into
his campaign now what's the response
from Donald Trump's lawyer mark caso
it's no surprise
focus on the fact that this was leaked
rather than the substance par for the
course a quote from Mark Corallo who's a
spokesman for Trump's attorney mark caso
it said the FBI leak of information
regarding the president is outrageous
inexcusable
and illegal Donald Trump's comments on
the matter they came at 6:55 a.m. this
morning via Twitter naturally saying
quote they made up a phony collusion
with the Russian story found zero proof
so now they go for obstruction of
justice on the phony story nice also
adding via Twitter you were witnessing
the single greatest witch hunt in
American political history led by some
very bad and conflicted people hashtag
make America great again
given how concerned Donald Trump has
been for months as to whether or not he
was personally under investigation it's
hard for me to imagine that that he's
taking this news particularly well and
remember Comey warned him Comey was
asked by Donald Trump in one of those
oval office meetings can you go out
there and say that I'm not under
investigation and James Comey said
listen you should think about whether
you want me to do that because once you
do that you are number one
putting that conversation in to the
public and you are creating a duty to
correct where if I go out there as FBI
director / James Comey and say Trump is
not under investigation personally if
that were to change at some point in the
future Comey would then have a duty to
correct that and say yeah those
circumstances have changed exactly what
Comey warned Trump about
is what is happening and that had to do
with the collusion angle now we're
approaching this obstruction of justice
angle yeah and Chris ruddy who's one of
trumps close friends say that he's
floating the idea of firing special
counsel Robert Moeller that's right that
was to happen I think the trains would
fall off trains off the rails the
paintings falling off the wall that you
know what hitting the fan of analogy
whatever analogy you want to use is what
would take place but I I don't want to
get hyperbolic we all need to remember
that even if evidence of crimes is found
against Donald Trump this is very
complex because the Justice Department
has held for a very long time not just
under Donald Trump that it would be
incredibly difficult if if even
potentially inappropriate to indict a
sitting president it would depend on
Congress to look at the evidence and say
this evidence warrants starting
impeachment proceedings and if that
happens Republicans would find
themselves in a very complex situation
complex in the sense that they'll be
thinking of their own reelection chances
morally if you're a sensible elected
official and an ethical elected official
and you're presented with evidence of
criminality by the president you say
impeach regardless of party Republicans
like most elected officials it's not
that Democrats are different would have
to decide what's worse impeaching a
president from my own party or ignoring
the potential crimes of a president of
my own party the answer will likely
depend on Trump's approval rating at the
time and how close we are to re-election
campaign yeah the sad thing is that if
the house was to impeach Trump then it
would be of course up to the Senate to
convict right in the Senate in that case
is supposed to act as if they're a jury
and usually when you select a jury you
do Pete where you choose people who are
going to be impartial aware of
everything not exactly and a half a
Senate no doubt about that we are living
in fascinating times Trump personally
under investigation now